south carolina republican congressman
trey Gowdy is chairman of the House
Oversight and Government Reform
Committee he joins us tonight from
Greenville welcome to back to special
report mr. chairman
Thank You Brett first of all on the
Cavanaugh situation your thoughts about
where we are now and this latest letter
from her attorney that there they're now
negotiating on her to testify
it's an incredibly serious allegation
that in my judgment bread is not
mitigated by the passage of time it's an
equally straightforward denial by Judge
Cavanaugh when when the suspect says I
was not even at the scene of the party
that's a classic credibility context one
witness says that I was physically and
sexually assaulted to the point that I
was in fear for my life and the person
that she names as the suspect says I was
not even at the party so the only way I
know to reconcile that is for dr. Ford
to testify and for judge Cavanaugh to
testify and for good fair but firm
questions to be asked about I don't know
how an FBI investigation would help
unless they're able to locate witnesses
that can either corroborate or
contradict there was no crime scene to
analyze there are no forensics to
analyze and the FBI can't interview her
and judge Cavanaugh and then repeat back
what they say that you can't determine
credibility that way so I hope that she
comes I hope that she will will testify
I think she'll be treated fairly I would
hope that she would and I think judge
Kavanaugh should also be given an
opportunity to respond to it you
mentioned the FBI investigation call and
that really is what Democrats are saying
the most here is Senator Doug Jones and
also Sheldon Whitehouse I prosecuted
thirty eight-year-old cases so they're
they're pretty good about locating
witnesses and finding people that's
their job they're a hell of a lot better
at it then the Senate majority or
minority staff that's what the FBI does
that's what they're trained to do but
even if they were to REM this guy
through as soon as Democrats get gavels
we're gonna want to get to the bottom of
this if the Democrats win back the house
and or the Senate Democrats will
investigate what happened
I am confident of that and I think we'll
also be investigating why the FBI stood
down its background investigation when
this came up all right there's two I
want one more senator Kirsten Gillibrand
just a few moments ago earlier this
afternoon Judge Cavanaugh has not asked
to have the FBI review these claims is
that the is that the reaction of an
innocent person it is not can you get
reaction to all of those Wow
I when I walked into the studio tonight
there was a presumption of innocence and
you did not have to prove your innocence
so I'm a little surprised at what the
senator from New York said Brett I'll
tell you this I think that dr. Ford met
with Democrat legislatures before the
FBI investigated it I know that she
talked to the Washington Post before the
FBI investigated it the FBI does not
have jurisdiction over state sex assault
claims if they want to locate witnesses
if there are witnesses that know whether
or not this happened I'm all for and I'm
all for them being compelled to come
testify but but the FBI does not have
jurisdiction over a state sex assault
claim and judge Kavanaugh does not have
the burden of proving his innocence he
has said he was not present the last
time I checked the government has the
burden of proof in a criminal case now
if someone argued well this isn't
criminal you know Brett he was vetted
for the second highest court in the land
15 years ago these are incredibly
serious allegations if they make you
unfit for the highest court in the land
would they also not make you unfit for
the second highest court in the land
sounds like it's going to continue even
if he gets through according to Sheldon
Whitehouse I want to turn topics you
know the Senate Judiciary Committee is
obviously investigating all that and
they say they're there on top of the
Cavanaugh investigation even though
Democrats are not taking part now to the
topic of the declassification here's the
former CIA director on this order by the
president to declassify these documents
and texts I think they could should
continue to push push push if mr. Trump
in the White House does not relent well
then I think they have some decisions to
make whether or not they're going
just not follow that direction and be
fired or to resign they have an
obligation since they took an oath of
office to the Constitution United States
not to mr. Trump to uphold their
responsibilities so he's essentially
saying to intelligence officials don't
do it I've read every document that is
under consideration Brett I don't think
the release of this information is going
to change anyone's mind it's certainly
not going to change John Brennan's mind
because remember he wanted a Donald
Trump put on the dustbin of history
he's accused him of treasonous conduct
John Brennan is this responsible for the
American public being divided on this
issue is anyone I can possibly think of
so I honestly no disrespect intended to
him could really give a damn less what
John Brennan thinks the president or the
intelligence agencies should do he's
part of the reason that we are in this
historic conundrum I've read it other
than then one document related George
papadopolis I don't think people are
going to be that interested in it and I
don't think any minds going to be
changed I think the bias of Peter struck
has resulted in us having a hung jury
frankly no matter what comes out and for
all the talk abouts concern on sources
and methods you're one of the only
people who's read through the unredacted
papers what about that I would tell
Chris and Dan Coates and and everyone
else by the way all of whom were Trump
appointees that if you are concerned
about sources and methods if you're
concerned about relationships with
friendly foreign governments then you
need to go sit down with the President
and say look there's a way we can get
this information out but safeguard
sources and methods I would think the
president would be open to that in fact
I know we would so if Chris is concerned
if Dan kosis concerned they have
unfettered access to the president and
they can go make the case I've read it
some of us embarrassing for the
Department of Justice some of it's
embarrassing for the FBI embarrassment
is not a reason to classify something so
a lot of it should be embarrassing to
John Brennan and maybe therein lies why
he is so adamant that this information
not be released I've read it I don't
think it's going to change humans mind
but I've seen nothing in it that is
going to jeopardize the national
security interests of this country last
thing quickly mr. chairman do you think
Attorney General Sessions keeps his job
the president continues talking about
the Attorney General the other day
saying telling the hill I don't have an
attorney general you know Brett I think
we're at the point of irreconcilable
differences in this relationship and I
think he keeps chef sessions until a
sufficient number of Republican senators
tell the president that someone else can
be confirmed I don't know who that
person could be in this hyper political
environment I hated that job of all the
cabinet level jobs out is the one that I
am most interested in having the right
person in and I hate that the
president's relationship with Jeff
Sessions has become what it is and I
hate that it's become public but I think
he's gonna be the AG until someone else
can be confirmed and I don't know who
that person would be is he you heavens
no I'm not sure I could get the vote of
my two Republican couple or Tim Scott
problem was that Lindsey I think would
be undecided last thing we glass talks
you said you hadn't seen any evidence of
Russian collusion at all still true
today yeah Brett the only thing is Adam
Schiff in March of 2017 saying he had
evidence there was more than
circumstantial but not direct and oh by
the way there is no such thing but if
you can lay aside Adam Schiff the
wannabe senator from California no one
has presented any evidence and the best
way for that to be proven is released
all the transcripts of all the witness
interviews we did during 26 2017 down a
house Intel all of them Jared Kushner
Donald Trump jr.
Susan Rice Samantha power released all
of them because I asked every witness
give me all the evidence you have a
pollution coordination conspiracy
regardless of whether or not you even
believed it every bit of evidence you
have no one had anything so there is no
evidence of collusion which is why the
Democrats have pivoted to obstruction of
justice mr. chairman as always we
appreciate your time thank you Brett